[Music]
if we think about materials as active
and Alive where would that lead us in
sense of everyday objects everyday
rituals
like Hotel Society is important
[Music]
I am a designer researcher and filmmaker
and my practice is based on field of
design which is called speculative
design my name is Leah pavoda and I'm a
postdoctoral researcher at the cluster
of Excellence matters of activity at
Humboldt University it's Berlin and I am
the co-leader of the project Collective
materials my vision for this project is
to co-create a space where people from
the public and researchers from our
clusters can exchange on eye level
Collective materials is a project where
we engage together with different people
from the public about questions of
materials of our material Futures and we
want to ask each other how the materials
of our futures could look like what
relationship we have to them
[Music]
you know in modernity you took the
materials as something passive and
perhaps even passivated them with with
technology if you think about plywood or
or concrete and
and we were trying to imagine like how
the future would look like if you would
take the materials as active and as a
life and with their own agency that you
could perhaps collaborate with
so this kind of different relation to
materials was the core idea of the
workshop so the participants of the
workshop should imagine what kind of
everyday objects of this bio-inspired
world with active materials or living
Technologies could look like
and later on we kind of went from more
abstract ideas towards this kind of
everyday objects that would be then
exhibited in the exhibition and you know
that would then capsulate how how the
speculative future could look like so it
was kind of a mixture of of first
thinking things individually and then
bringing that into a group and thinking
through there's a group
we just had our first public speculation
event with Collective materials so there
are some quite fresh expressions from
this experience we were gathering in
small groups and we didn't know each
other before so we were just this ad hoc
community of speculators
[Music]
so usually you take scientific research
that it's not yet
developed as a technology
you accelerate it
into the future
and imagine what kind of societal
impacts this technology might have in
the future when it has become
an everyday application of the
technology and you take these ideas
in today as objects as materialized
ideas of that societal change so that's
kind of the the classical pattern of of
how to do speculative design in the
essence of speculative design there's
also this idea that it should never
become kind of an
pinned down method because it is that
kind of field of design that goes
against that idea you know so it's kind
of the Rebel in design so when it
becomes a method
that you know it kind of loses something
so it should be always in shift always
and change it's kind of the essence of
this way of making
I'm really interested of bringing
speculative design or something that can
engage people and have this idea of more
inclusive scientific futures
we really see some great potential and
applying the method of speculative
design for science communication because
it takes the process of how we take a
piece of research or some
findings as an Impulse but it also asks
about attached questions that are yet
Unthinkable what I really like about
speculative design in this sense is that
it um
challenges us to step a bit out of our
habits and our usually usual way of
doing things and maybe even leave behind
a bit like this idea and our
self-understanding as researchers
what is this new approach to materials
about we
are using the method of speculative
design as a means for science
communication
science communication is really at the
center stage of this endeavor
we need public engagement and an
exchange on questions of materiality and
material Futures because they apply to
all of us
the science Communication in classical
sense has been about educating people
about science and you know within this
project
we thought that maybe we could find a
way where the participants could be in a
more active role we were speculative
design you can really
make these ideas and features and
questions uh tangible that people might
have it's not about finding Solutions
it's read about asking new questions we
believe that this new approach is also
necessary to tackle some of the most
pressing and Urgent ecological
challenges of our time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]